hey i just want to be clear with you  it's okay  it's okay for a man to go into the  women's section  show his penis  around the other woman young little  girls under age your spa we spa could  donate is that what you're saying  like i asked  it's so he he could stay there  he could stay there  what sexual orientation i see  it lets me know he's a man  he's a man  he is a man he is not no female you know  you could probably sit through about 10  hours of of sexuality studies women's  sex and gender studies at harvard or  yale or somewhere else and and have them  try to explain to you the meaning of the  deconstruction of the gender and then  this and then that and then this woman  could go up there and she'd say okay  here's my counterpoint i see a phallus  that's that's what lets me know that  he's a man